- Gettin' a real
fucking work out, man.
Real stuff.
You agree?
- Killing it.
Bench rows.
- Rows. Bench.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Gary] Alright,
alright, alright.
Here we go, here we go.
Facebook good to see you.
Let's see.
We are live.
I hope everybody's
super well
and doing great.
Enjoying their weekend.
Trying to find different ways
to hack DailyVees when
I'm not surrounded
by Tyler and DRock
and all those characters so
decided to do a Q&amp;A
on Facebook as today's DailyVee.
While this audience builds,
why don't I yap a little bit and
tell you guys
maybe week recap.
Tomorrow's #BizDevSunday
but today it was a good week.
I was in Ireland.
I was in Brussels,
last couple episodes of DailyVee
have been remarkably strong.
Oh, by the way, you
guys have to see this.
This is actually amazing.
Some of you have
seen this already.
This is my Macho Man hoodie.
But this is really,
I mean this pretty remarkable.
I'm actually gonna do this
entire DailyVee as Macho Man,
oh yeah, Macho Man Randy Savage.
- Yeah.
I'm justifiably in a position
that I'd rather not be in but
the cream will rise to the top.
- Oh yeah!
Alright, so, I'm
gonna do this DailyVee as
Macho Man Randy Savage.
Let's do this,
let's do some Q&amp;A.
What I learned in Ireland and
Belgium is that so many people
still are just looking for
permission to do their thing.
Way too many people asking
and looking for permission.
So what do you think your
biggest weakness was in your
mid-20s that kept you from
reaching your current status?
Henry, I'll be honest with you.
I think way too many people are
paying close attention to their
weaknesses even this is I think
symbolic and I think the theme
of maybe this
episode which is, Henry,
I'll be honest with you, I'm not
sure what my biggest weaknesses
were and I'm not sure what
everybody's weaknesses are but
I know that way too
many people focus on them.
I would be blown away and
happy if more people would pay
attention to their strengths
versus their weaknesses.
I don't know what my
big weaknesses were at 20.
I really don't care.
I knew my
strengths were selling,
leadership, intuition
of where the market was,
not being fearful of new
technologies and my answer to
your question is you're asking
me to give you an answer about a
weakness of mine so
that you could address this.
I would tell you that your
biggest weakness is the same
biggest weakness that I see from
99% of people which is you are
more inclined to focus on your
weaknesses than your strengths.
This is the binary switch.
To me, this
like a switch, right?
To me, this is like,
to me this is very simple.
I'll give you an example.
Here it is.
To me, it's this.
It's just a switch, right?
Either you're on or you're off
and to me way too many people
are on on their weaknesses and
I just want to
be on my strengths.
So that's my answer for that and
that will be the theme of this
episode which is enough
focusing on fucking weaknesses.
I mean we have to get
serious about strengths.
We just have to, please, please.
Anyway couple more questions
and we'll keep it going.
What are the top five things
angel investors look for in
early-stage startups?
Israel at this point in 2017,
this is a huge
mistake for so many.
They don't
realize this is the case.
(mumbling) over.
No more bullshit startups
getting funded that the 2007,
actually, 2010 to
2015 bubble is over.
Israel you need to
actually make a business now.
You need traction.
You need hundreds of thousands
of users or you're gonna get
shitty VCs or dumb money.
So, news alert another
theme of this episode,
bet on your strengths.
Here's a second theme.
The party's fucking over.
Dumb fucking businesses are not
getting funded the way they were
three, four, five years ago.
Two, three years ago,
even 18 months ago.
The supply and demand
of real entrepreneurs,
real good startups is really
difficult to figure out now and
people are being
way more selective.
The angel investors that
I grew up with the Dave Morins,
the Saccas, you
know, the Kevin Roses,
the Travises have gone on to
either build great funds of big
businesses or focus on their own
thing and so I think you got to
actually build
something with traction.
GaryVee, I'm 39.
I just started my own
business in September
as a health and fitness coach.
What advice would
you have for me to
get word out there
through advertising?
Francis, there's
a lot of, you know,
there's a lot of ways.
I mean I did an episode on how
to do DM marketing on Instagram
not too long ago.
Hustling 24/7 on
the Instagram DM.
It is the 2017 opportunity.
Content every day.
You know, hashtags on Instagram.
DMing other
Instagram fitness people.
Just putting in the work, man.
Patience, I mean
you just started.
Everybody, you know,
there's so many ways to do it.
If you've got money, you run
Facebook ads and influencer ads.
If you don't you just
put out content and you wait.
I think way too many people when
they start off with zero are
fancy and they're not
putting in enough free work.
Free has such a
negative, you know,
it's not free when
you don't have anything.
I love when people are
like don't do free work.
If I was a trainer and
nobody knew who I was I would DM
everybody who has 100,000 to
500,000 followers or more on
Instagram and offered
to do it for free, right?
Period.
You know and so, I just I don't
understand why so many of you
that are just starting
out are so damn fancy.
My biggest strategy when you're
zero and nobody wants to pay is
to do shit for free and
then use the exposure for,
you know, for new clients.
I mean to me I love
doing shit for free.
And so, that would be
my number one strategy.
Do free workouts with people
that have huge audiences and
tell them you'll give them
and it's not a free workout,
you're asking for
exposure in return.
You know?
That's kind of how I see it.
We cut radio, direct mail,
Facebook drives sales
into our brick-and-mortar.
Any thoughts on how to
leverage traditional channels
to drive social?
No, Chad.
Just use more
social to drive social.
Like you don't need
traditional to drive Facebook.
Do more Facebook,
do more Instagram influencers.
You know, do more
searching on Twitter.
Do more digital.
You know, like why are
we holding onto traditional.
Fuck traditional.
And fuck digital if
it doesn't work like
banner ads or pre-rolls.
You know or overpriced
or things of that nature.
Little hot tip
on this Saturday night,
Snapchat's open
filter marketplace.
Five dollars an hour
for 20,000 square feet.
You make a custom filter,
it's incredible branding.
More and more of you
have to pay attention to it.
Check it out geo-filter
on demand geo-filters,
check it out.
I'm starting to
really get excited about it.
Cool, one more question.
And thanks for all of you for
hanging out on this Saturday.
Appreciate it, thank you so much
for all of you that giving love
on Instagram.
It's really going
down on Instagram.
Look at this, John Bates, I've
been in the fitness industry for
over 30 years and I've done
thousands of free workouts.
Right on.
("Mixed Feelings"
by Derek Pope)
that's why you've
been in it for 30 years.
People are coming into some new
market for 30 minutes and they
think they're fancy and they're
like I'm not doing spec work.
My time is worth something.
Your time ain't worth shit if
nobody's willing to pay for it.
If nobody's willing
to pay for your shit,
your time's worth
zero, mother fucker.
Anyway, shit gets me mad.
Everybody's so fancy now.
Fancy damn entrepreneurs.
Fucking bled out
my eyes my whole life.
People think it's like luck.
And like privilege
or stumbled into shit.
Put in work mother fuckers.
When you're at zero, I came into
the agency world after building,
you know,
$60 million wine business,
built up my brand,
books, speeches and
I still did work for free 'cause
I was now in Madison Avenue and
I had to establish myself there.
I'm not getting paid anywhere
close to my commissions for my
time now at VaynerSports
helping AJ build that.
When you're in something new,
the market doesn't give a shit
what you were before.
Nobody cared that
The Rock was the best wrestler.
Now that he came to Hollywood,
he had to pay his dues.
Nobody gave a shit.
Nobody gives a shit of
what you came from before.
When you come into something
new you got to fucking work.
I built a huge wine store,
wanted to get into tech,
you know what I did my
first three tech meet ups?
I didn't walk in
like I was somebody.
Even though I had
a top 1,000 followed.
I was one of 1,000 top followed
people on Twitter on my way to
being a top 100 and boom,
boom, I get into the tech world.
First three meet ups
I pour wine like I'm the help.
I'm a fucking waiter.
Like I'm the fucking help
because I knew
I had to eat shit.
I'm ending it with this.
That's it.
There's nothing else to say.
Like people are fucking fancy.
Get to fucking work.
Here I am fucking
family, Saturday night.
At the top of the game but I
made a commitment to do a daily
vlog so I got to hack it.
What do I do?
I get on fucking Facebook and
answer questions for 10 minutes.
I don't want to
necessarily do that but
I got to put in the work.
You want to win,
climb the mountain,
put in the work.
Love you guys.
Thanks for having me.
See you tomorrow.
'Cause you're smart John,